from Florida politics New National GOP
2024 poll shows Ronda sandis in third
place behind obviously the ramaswami in
the prediction market right now let me
see if I can uh I don't know I got real
there we go this is crazy when I saw
this I'm you know we were talking about
it before that even when they're tied VI
is below Ronda santis and it could be
because D becomes for R in the in you
alphabetical order whatever but as of
right now this one blew my mind VI
ramaswami and the prediction market for
predict it is in second place three
points above Ronda santis now I'll make
a few things clear in this prediction
markets are not polls it's the sentiment
of people do they who do they think is
going to win they are basically betting
money in real time like stocks on who
they think is going to improve Ronda
santis going down means people think
they will lose money by holding shares
in his prediction Mark in his prediction
contract and people are buying vake at
17 cents because because they believe it
will actually increase these are not
polls we had uh you know with Bill MIT
Bill Mitchell was discussing this with
us earlier in the culture War podcast
and he said you know and we had Cal
Becker as well Becker said that real
clear politics is better I do prefer
aggregate polling instead of singular
polls like they mentioned this one
article that he's in second place yeah
well the I think has like three polls
showing him in second and DeSantis has
like eight but these polls go back a
week or two or two or three weeks or
even a month so when they do these
aggregate polling just consider the
difference between prediction markets
which is realtime short-term changes and
prediction markets which is long-term
sentiment there's there's reasons to
weigh both differently but for the time
being I will tell you one of the things
I think that's helping the right now the
reason why he may have jumped up is that
at 3:05 a.m. this morning Elon Musk
tweeted he States his beliefs
clearly re rexing I guess quoting the
Gras Swami says truth God is real there
are two genders human flourishing
requires fossil fuels reverse racism is
racism an open border is no border
parents determine the education of their
children the nuclear family is the
greatest form of governance known to
known to mankind capitalism lifts people
up from poverty there are three branches
of the US government not four the US
Constitution is the strongest guarantor
of freedoms in history Elon Musk is now
promoting VI I mean they they love this
guy I'm wondering do we do we see this
continue does VI overtake Ronda santis
what do you think is going to happen in
next week's debate yeah I think
so easy enough all right I agree moving
on I mean I have a lot I have a lot more
to say but I just talked a lot so I'll
let other people talk I I I just don't
feel like there's a lot of of of ground
swell appreciation of Ronda santis like
people can you know say what they want
about his record they're people that are
going to cast in in Florida I mean as a
governor they're people that are going
to cast it as positive there are people
that are going to cast it as negative
and stuff but at the end of the day um
people tend to vote with you know with
their gut more than with their you know
with their with with their belief in
policy or whatever and I think that it
is more likely that vake is going to
going to communicate with people better
than Ron does and that might be because
of the fact that you know apparently Ron
has this is what I this is what I've
heard but Ron has a problem relating to
people he's not the you know he's not
the guy you're going to want to have a
beer with like the old George W bush
line was I we we've had V on the show
IRL twice I was here once it was when we
were at we actually using Charlie Kirk
Studio down in Florida that or in
Arizona sorry that was awesome and then
he came on here when Sheamus was guest
hosting but I also got to talk to him on
the culture war and he's easy guy to
communicate with he will answer the
question you ask him even if it's very
very difficult he is quick witted and
smart he he handles it very very well
and he's really good with liberal cuz he
could handle
me I changed the subject I'm asking
about Mars colonization he was all about
it he's he's got an answer he's he so
let's go back to the Aleppo moment the
the very terrible oh my God I wanted to
kill myself when that happened because
that was like my Peak like libertarian
guy I'm like now's our time man the
Libertarians Gary's got it here we go
and I'm watching Morning Joe and and
like and I'm just like my heart sank and
I'm like I I can't believe this for
those who are not familiar
this is uh Gary Johnson right yes he's
doing an interview and he's asked how
would he deal with Aleppo and he goes
and what is Aleppo yeah yeah Aleppo is a
city in Syria that was just just
flattened during the Civil War like at
the height of the time it ruined his it
ruined his campaign absolutely they were
talking about rocket they were talking
about like the end days and that was
like being spoken about on the news and
he had no clue so let's go through this
I told people like my viewers if Donald
Trump was asked a question about insert
random topic if he's sitting down and
someone and the interviewer said I want
to get your thoughts on Roberto the
rooster Trump having no idea what the
hell he's talking about would go no look
I know a lot of people want to talk
about Roberto but we got to focus on
jobs in this country we've got a border
that's worth he would he would adapt and
pivot the smart enough to do the same
thing Ron would do some fact simil of I
don't see him being quick wited enough
to deal with these difficult situations
another thing another thing that's going
to happen that you're going to see is
that you know vamas swame has written
books about woke culture and he's going
to uh well Ronda santis is going to find
out very quickly that uh just talking
about woke and talking about Disney and
talking about coid and pretending to be
against uh childhood transitions isn't
going to be enough to get him through
this debate uh Rhonda santis has an
issue as you just said uh communicating
with people and relating to people and
he doesn't really have that likability
factor uh you see that he very awkward
in person and this because he's this is
because he's on the Spectrum uh Politico
you could pull up the article if you
want
actually wrote an article about how
Rhonda santis might be autistic and
there are lawmakers in the Florida
legislature who have uh talked about how
he has Aspergers I know people who have
worked with Ronda santis in the past
former staffers who have said that he
has Aspergers I'm not saying that
there's anything wrong with people who
have Aspergers but obviously one of the
issues that comes with you know being on
the Spectrum or having some form of
autism is that sometimes you lack social
skills right that's one of the main
characteristics about it and so Ronda
santis right you'll see him in these in
these situations where people will come
up to him and say there was one that
I'll never forget where he was I believe
in Iowa and somebody goes oh I just
drove eight hours to come see you and
Ronda Sanchez goes oh great and he walks
away like he didn't even ask the guy
like if you want a photo or how you
doing and so theas swame has written
books about woke and Ron's not going to
be able to get away with just saying oh
you know like yeah we're going to we're
going to combat wokeism well how is Ron
going to combat wokeism when one of his
top lobbies is a guy named Slater bis
who's a lobbyist for budlight how is he
going to combat childhood transitioning
with another one of his top lobbyists is
a guy named Mark lampin who represents a
company called ABY okay a pharmaceutical
company called ABY that is the
manufacturer of a drug called Lupron
which is a drug used to chemically
castrate children you understand like he
needs to be called out for this
hypocrisy what you're what you're
talking about with the about uh you know
and and to STIs about woke is is a great
point because V really understands the
philosophy behind that's going on the
left now I don't know exactly how deep
Ron's understanding is I don't feel like
Ron really you know understands the the
philosophies behind it whereas I do feel
like understand exactly you know he
understands he's he knows who Mark
Hughes is you know he knows the leftists
that are writing the philosophies and
writing the academic papers that are
having significant effects on the
culture today so he's aware of the of
the actual problems in the philosophy a
lot of a lot of people are going to say
oh you know we're talking about vake and
Ron it's like well yes these are the
guys fighting behind Trump for the next
position so I think it's it's warranted
I don't I don't care to say if Ron's on
the Spectrum or whatever that seems I
don't know whatever tough to measure no
but who cares right we can just say it
simply is bad with people yeah we're not
trying to I'm not trying to be
derogatory I'm just saying that it would
explain why he has such a hard time uh
communicating with people and you'll see
the Never Back Down pack and you'll see
his campaign say oh well we ra $150
million which you know it's not really
true right that's another lie but all
the money in the world as I said this
money isn't going to be enough to buy
Ronda santis the personality transplant
that he so desperately needs I saw the
video of him serving eggs to people and
he wasn't looking at them and they
didn't even know who the hell he was in
Iowa and then you have Bill Mitchell on
this morning being like Oh yeah Bob
Vander plat is a king maker in Iowa and
Ronda santz is gonna win I mean the
guy's literally putting toothpicks and
eggs as Donald Trump flies his plane
over and cucks him in real time Donald
Donald Trump there is no question is so
good super good with P you know you want
a fist bunp fist you didn't see air fist
bump yeah that's what I was laughing
fist bum go Trump so Trump walks into a
room and he commands this entertaining
presence yeah I went to the White House
for the social media Summit and and and
I didn't know what to expect and Trump
was basically doing standup for an hour
and we were all laughing he was just
nailing it Ron is the opposite of that V
nowhere near as good as Trump's
commanding presence but at the very
least he can hold his own in a
conversation with quick wit I guess the
question is though where does v go he's
not going to be Trump he's not going to
be president what is he doing where does
he end up a cabinet position perhaps I
thought so I think he wants a cabinet
position I think it's obvious that V is
not going to be president but I do
appreciate the fact that he actually is
running the campaign that Rond de santis
if he wanted to run for President should
have been running right yep Z raas swame
was the only other candidate for
president that showed up to the rally I
organized in front of the Miami
Courthouse when President Trump was
arraigned he had a press conference and
that was a really big Act of Courage
because think about it those are all
Trump supporters there he knows he
didn't know if he was going to get booed
or he was going to get chased away but
actually the Trump supporters there
embraced him and went up to him and
thanked him because he passed out uh you
know a a a press statement saying that
when if he were to get elected as
president the first thing he would do is
pardon president Trump and has not
really attacked president Trump much I
haven't really seen any direct attacks
and in fact he's always the first one to
come out with a statement whenever Trump
has an indictment unlike Ronda Santos
who pretends like he doesn't know what's
going on and waits 24 hours to issue a
statement and then won't even say
Trump's name I think you nailed it when
you said V is running the campaign to
Santa should have run because V is
setting him setting himself up for
what's after this election I think he's
another another level VI is like a
brilliant genius Mastermind business
strategist he's I think Trump sees a lot
of himself in VI which is why he
respects him so much from when he was a
young entrepreneur and but but VI is
like top level one
0.00001% genius human so you know
whether or not he's not as famous As
Trump so I that's why I personally feel
like Trump's name recognition is going
to get him 50 million votes thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net